Shoshanna loves doing ballet and
gymnastics at 3:00 she's full of energy
but with parks closed and classes
canceled because of coronavirus she's
finding new ways to keep active the
corona virus pandemic has led to a big
upsurge in online fitness classes for
all ages from yoga and dance to a high
intensity cardio workout and football
it's all out there some people are even
managing to run marathons inside here in
the UK all gyms and leisure centres have
closed their doors and some parks are
off-limits because of the risk of
transmitting the virus restrictions mean
that people are being urged by Britain's
government to exercise just once a day
and only with members of your own
household for many people Fitness is
part of their daily or weekly life and
under normal circumstances this place is
full of golfers of all different ages
and abilities but they can't play at the
moment
Steve McGinty is a retired PE teacher
who plays golf and swims regularly and
if you give up and say oh I can't really
be bothered to do my exercise program
today then you're definitely feeling at
the end of the day you feel that you
have not achieved anything and therefore
in some ways ironically that kind of
Spurs you want to do more the next day
many of us are changing our lives
significantly during this crisis to stay
safe and trying to stay fit is a
challenge but doctors say it could also
help protect us now and in the future I
think it's really important to take
advantage of any opportunities that you
do have to exercise whether you know
you're allowed to go outside for walk
really taking advantage of that and also
utilizing some of the videos that might
be available online or things that you
might be able to do in the home with
yourself your family members your kids
maybe teaming up with some friends over
the Internet and you know really holding
each other to account to trying to get
in some of that physical exercise every
day not only is that going to be good
for your physical health it's also going
to be good for your mental health some
people are using this time to try out
new ways of keeping fear
none of us know how long this crisis
will last or how long will be asked to
alter our lives
Emma Haywood al Jazeera Lincolnshire